Lucretia:
Allo? Allo ?
C'est Astrid ?
Astrid:
Hurle pas, j'suis le seul numéro enregistré.
Bon, j'en ai capturé un.
Lucretia:
Chut! Pas toi, Aliénor.
Tu veux dire, un cyber-historien?
Astrid:
Un de leurs agents, ouais.
Figure-toi que son ancêtre, c'est le barman
de là où je squattais.
Il a essayé de me coincer à la sortie en
se faisant passer pour lui, et j'suis compromise
là-bas maintenant. Bref.
J'ai commencé à le travailler gentiment,
si j'ai plus d'infos...
Lucretia:
Non non non, tu nous attends, parce que...
On est une équipe, hein ?
Astrid:
Grouillez-vous alors, j'en ai marre de l'entendre gémir.
J't'envoie l'adresse.
Lucretia:
Comment? Comment tu m'envoies l'adresse ?
T'envoies un pigeon voyageur ?
Aliénor:
On y va, on y va?
Lucretia:
C'était pas vraiment facile à trouver, ton antre.
Aliénor:
Il est où l'agent? J'suis chaude!
Astrid:
J'ai juste attaqué un peu les ongles.
Agent:
C'est moi, l'agent.
Sauvez-moi de cette folle.
Aliénor:
Alors écoute-moi, l'agent de la cyber-histoire.
J'ai rien contre toi, mais apparemment tu
veux notre peau, à moi
et à ma descendante alcoolique.
Et à mon ancêtre reloue.
Alors tu vas me dire tout ce que tu sais,
maintenant.
J'ai pas l'habitude de torturer les gens,
mais j'ai lu tout ce qu'il fallait savoir
sur les ordalies depuis que je suis ici, et
j'hésiterai pas à m'en servir.
Tu vas parler ou j'te gave d'hostie jusqu'à
ce qu'elles te ressortent par les...
Lucretia:
Aliénor!
Agent:
Sauvez-moi de cette folle.
Astrid:
Relève-toi, Aliénor, laisses-en un peu pour
les autres.
Aliénor:
C'est pas juste, t'as déjà commencé.
On fait quoi alors? On lui met une barre
de fer rougi dans les mains?
Lucretia:
Si nous avions un aigle, on pourrait lui faire dévorer le foie.
J'ai lu ça dans un vieux livre.
Astrid:
Moi j'dis, on arrache les morceaux qui dépassent
jusqu'à ce qu'il en puisse plus.
Agent:
Non, mais...
J'veux bien parler, en fait.
J'suis un peu douillet, alors si on pouvait
éviter...
Tout ce que vous dites.
Je préférerais.
Aliénor:
Parle!
Agent:
Ok...
Alors je fais qu'obéir aux ordres, d'accord,
on m'a dit de vous tuer parce que vous êtes
des anachronismes...
Aliénor:
Qui est-ce que tu traites d'anachronismes?
Astrid:
Marin d'eau douce.
Lucretia:
Ce n'est pas une insulte, pour votre information.
Agent:
Je peux continuer? Bref, si quelqu'un peut
vous gracier, c'est votre cyber-historienne,
mais elle est au XXIIIe siècle.
Lucretia:
Parfait, conduis-nous à elle.
Aliénor:
Attends un peu!
Astrid:
Quoi? Si c'est un piège, je m'en fous.
On fonce.
Aliénor:
Mais non, c'est pas ça.
Pourquoi notre cyber-historienne voudrait
nous tuer alors que si elle le fait, on meurt?
Lucretia:
Il t'as fallu combien de temps pour penser à ça ?
Aliénor:
Non, mais je veux dire, j'ai pas d'enfants moi !
Alors si je meurs, j'ai pas de descendance,
Astrid existe pas, la Prof non plus, et la
cyber-historienne non plus! Aaaah, t'y avais
pas pensé, hein l'agent?
Agent:
Elle est sérieuse?
Astrid:
On sait tout ça, mais quand on a voyagé
dans le temps ça a crée une sorte de paradoxe,
c'est compliqué...
En gros si on retourne pas à notre époque,
un double parallèle apparaît et prend notre place.
Tu peux pas comprendre.
Agent:
Et bim.
Aliénor:
C'est dégueulasse.
Lucretia:
Bref.
Tu nous conduis au XXIIIe siècle, on parle
à ta patronne, et on rentre chez nous.
Veni, vidi, vici.
La Prof:
Mais c'est quoi ce bordel! Me dites pas
que vous avez tué quelqu'un?
Aliénor:
Mortecouille.
Lucretia:
Comment nous as-tu trouvées?
La Prof:
J'vous ai géolocalisées.
Aliénor:
Sorcellerie...
Astrid:
Mais bordel!
Aliénor:
C'est ta faute tout ça!
Lucretia:
Je veux rentrer chez moi...
La Prof:
STOP! .
Vous m'expliquez ce qui se passe, et si je
peux vous aider, je le fais.
Dans le calme!